serious questions to Hogwarts students
learn math or take a health class I mean
it's great that you can summon a
Patronus
but you can't multiply and you never
learned about preventing STDs is it
ethical to split children into houses
that will determine their personality
friends and future and leave it up to
some dick hat
he's probably racist does Azkaban
violate the Geneva Convention I feel
like it does and is this the only jail I
mean do I go there for weed
Voldemort saw muggles is inferiors and
wanted to crush them under his boot so
shouldn't the good guys want the
opposite you know to blend their worlds
and live in peace no instead the good
guys think muggles are equal but keep
them separate separate but equal Hank
can we talk about centaurs if old amor
wants maybe hairy dead why bother with
the wand why not just drown him or punch
him to death how hard is it for someone
evil to kill a baby it's like the one
thing muggles can do just as well as
wizards why does everyone use silverware
when they could just Accio food directly
into their mouths I would if Dumbledore
is so kind
why did he hire a squib as a janitor you
could magic the aviary clean but you're
making Filch scrub birds by hand yeah
buddy you dick though we're Moses and
Jesus wizards I mean is Christianity a
muggle attempt at making sense of magic
or is this a wizard conspiracy to throw
us off the scent either way I think we
can agree that Jesus was a Hufflepuff
he's a Gryffindor is the wizard gene
inherited are their magic lorian's what
keeps Wizards from magically duplicating
everything they buy is their magical drm
to keep the broom business on lock the
pirate bro why is reminding to Ron if
we're reading books about wizards for
escapism do they read about muggles is
there a series of books about Harvey
plane boy normal seventh grader people
are time-traveling changing their
appearance drunk up love potions
pretending to be my dog when you're
actually a fifty year old man
how can Wizards trust anybody and how
many galleons our wizard therapists
making hella sickles and nuts I'll bet
is it nuts or Canute's
it's Canute's in the audiobook but that
sounds terrible
knowledge is power seriously they're
centaurs we're just we're not going to
talk about that I said No
so if all those pipes in the school lead
to the Chamber of Secrets isn't that
giant dead basileus gonna stank things
up some stank gas basileus decomposing
in the basement someone should really
clean up that giant dead basilisk are
there homeschooled wizards are they
weird yes
why no kids go straight to prison as
soon as the Hat puts them into Slytherin
seems like they could just cut out the
middleman should a teenage girl really
be given the power to manipulate time
I mean maybe just encourage her to you
know like chill if Voldemort started a
war with humans would we be screwed or
could you just like new cog words
so house elves Hermione's the first
person to call that out that's it we're
leaving it not gonna talk about the
Centaurs okay quit it she have like that
bludgers and stuff and they're all worth
like 10 25 points whatever but then you
have the Golden Snitch going on
completely parallel to the game that's
worth so many points it makes whatever
else is going on irrelevant it's like
having the Super Bowl but the outcomes
determined by a fencing match happening
on the sidelines it makes no goddamn
sense are there sex bells
[Music]
subscribe
you